okay Donald Trump is going to very very
quickly take us to the dark ages uh
Donald Trump tweeted this morning that
he would like to see Americans lose
their citizenship or be put in jail for
a year for burning an American flag why
haven't they taken Twitter away from
Donald Trump yet here is his tweet from
this morning that Donald Trump uh put
out uh saying that uh nobody should be
allowed to burn the American flag if
they do there must be consequences
perhaps loss of citizenship or year in
jail this seems as well thought out is
when Trump said women who have abortions
should be punished how would this even
work if you were born in the US and you
have your citizenship revoked where do
you get deported to or what country do
you live in and of course Donald Trump
clearly has no idea that this is a major
legal issue we've seen anti flag burning
laws struck down by the supreme court
most recently in 1990 because they
violate this thing called the First
Amendment of the Constitution and it's
stunning Pat how the right is so quick
to call First Amendment fouls where they
don't exist like for example Oh Twitter
banned people free speech First
Amendment no the private company
enforcing what it is chosen to have as
its terms of service oh the Mozilla CEO
was asked to resign after it was
revealed that he made an anti-gay
political donation his free speech
rights were violated now his employer as
a private company decided that CEOs with
anti-gay donations in their in their
history aren't good for their business
we are the champions of the Constitution
oh but flag burning yeah jail for that
and I want to add to this Pat another
reason why Trump exposes that he's truly
clueless about everything is that you
aren't allowed to take citizenship away
as punishment there's a 1958 Supreme
Court decision which rejected the
practice of stripping US citizenship as
a form of criminal punishment this is
unbelievable yeah I mean this is the
essence I guess of the First Amendment
meant that you can attack even uh this
symbol of America for what it is and
that we stand up and support your right
to do that even though we may disagree
with what you're actually doing it's
amazing when you hear all veterans will
be angry if people burn the flag that
they fought to defend actually they
fought to defend the fact that in the
u.s. you're allowed to burn the flag if
you want and Jason Miller Trump senior
communications advisor visibly
struggling on CNN to defend these
comments and opting to go in the
direction of just pretending that this
didn't happen he refused to even
acknowledge when interviewed on CNN this
morning that it is constitutionally
protected activity to burn the American
flag wouldn't even acknowledge that and
played the look over here at something
else game take a look so let's try and
get the balance right this morning can
we agree that there's constitutional law
that burning the flag as much as we
might hate it is defended First
Amendment speech Chris I mean the flag
burning is completely ridiculous and I
think you know that I think the vast
majority of Americans would agree but
now but I but legal but Chris it's it's
completely ridiculous and I don't think
there's a they can universe of people
out there who support flag burning it's
terrible and it's it's despicable but
the big news though Christmas morning
you saw this I know we're going to get
to it dr. Tom Price run HHS and massima
Verma to run CMS two additional
administration pics i have a big big
impact on repealing obamacare i want to
talk about those but you know when the
president-elect says something in the
president united states if we got to
listen right when he says that something
should be illegal that are protected
constitutional right i'm not saying i
like it but that's a big part of the
First Amendment in this country a
frustrating maddening part of it is that
you got to respect people's ability to
say what you don't like to hear the
president just said burning the flag
should be illegal and he has a protected
constitutional right can we agree on
that no it would completely disagree
that this is don't think that the
Constitution I had been defended by the
Supreme Court in 1969 as validating
burning the flag as free speech Chris
absolutely should be illegal but again
we know ever hear this morning yeah
Jason Miller quickly
becoming the despicable slimy public
face of horrible things said by Donald
you won't even agree as to what the law
currently is that's not an opinion that
the question wasn't what is Trump want
we see what Trump wants the question was
just do you understand that this is the
law he wouldn't even agree to that right
these are the facts these actually
happen these cases young he wouldn't
even go along with those basic premises
this is the problem right here Jason
Miller saying I don't believe there are
a lot of people who want to burn the
flag well that's number one not the
question and number two that's the point
of the First Amendment we don't dismiss
issues or banned types of speech because
they're not common now here's where it
gets even better Donald Trump has not
been shy about expressing his love of
the late Supreme Court Justice Antonin
Scalia even Antonin Scalia believe that
flag burning was constitutionally
protected speech he sided with the flag
burning protesters in a 1989 case and
said that's the right decision based on
what the Constitution says saying if it
were up to me I would put in jail every
sandal-wearing scruffy bearded weirdo
who burns the American flag but i'm not
king and the constitution is very very
clear about this and there have been a
few attempts made to ban the desecration
of the phret flag over the last 20 30
years uh they've they've all failed this
man is a fundamental danger to the basic
tenets of the Constitution but I do want
to issue one warning pad which is this
could be bait this could be Trump
baiting protestors to start protesting
by burning flag after flag and you know
then that that will be used to to
characterize anti-trump protesters as on
American maybe one option is burn I
don't know Confederate flags or blonde
toupees or something else that could
work too but another interesting twist
of the story is the proper way to
dispose of an American flag is born is
burning it but you're supposed to fold
it up nicely and I guess say the Pledge
of Allegiance while it happens so I
guess that's acceptable we'll have to
see how the law plays out in those
different circumstances there's an
argument to be made that even wearing
those
egg pins is not actually following US
flag code but good luck communicating
that to those who seem very concerned
about the American flag